digamos que hace muchos años ustedes
comenzaron su propio negocio y ahora
ustedes no tienen ninguna deuda y su
negocio cada año genera un ingreso de
1.5 millones anuales una tercera parte
de esto va hacia los impuestos por lo
que les queda un ingreso neto de un
millón de dólares por año nada más todo
está muy estable y es muy poco probable
que este ingreso de un millón de dólares
aumente o disminuya en los siguientes
años quien si es como luce el balance de
su estado de cuenta aquí están sus
bienes no tienen deudas no tienen
pasivos o lo que ustedes tienen todo su
patrimonio sobre todos los activos pero
ustedes ya están pensando en el retiro y
pues quieren tener el efectivo de lo que
invirtieron en su negocio y no
necesariamente quieren vender su negocio
a sus competidores porque pues han
estado compitiendo con ellos durante
toda su vida de trabajo oa lo mejor no
hay competidores naturales en el tipo de
trabajo que ustedes manejan y ese
tampoco es un tipo de negocio en el que
puedan poner en la bolsa de valores pero
imaginemos que ustedes se encuentran
conmigo y yo les digo oye este negocio
parece muy interesante me gusta la idea
de que el negocio sea estable y que
genere ingresos año con año así que lo
que les digo es bueno me vendería su
negocio por 10 millones de dólares así
que yo ofrezco
10 millones de dólares y para ustedes
eso les pareció un muy buen precio ya
que es exactamente 10 veces lo que ganan
en un año y como no es un negocio que
esté creciendo está bastante estable no
van a ganar más que eso en un año por lo
que parece algo razonable para ustedes
por otro lado desde mi punto de vista yo
voy a pagar 10 millones de dólares por
un negocio que me da un millón de
dólares anuales que es el 10 por ciento
del dinero que estoy invirtiendo a lo
mejor yo puedo usar un apalancamiento y
no necesariamente invertir los 10
millones directamente de mi bolsillo a
lo mejor puedo tomar prestado algo de
eso y tener un ingreso mucho mejor de
esa manera cuando llegamos al momento de
hacer un cierre
voy a comprar los bienes los activos y
el dinero que yo junte para esos activos
van a llegar a ustedes directamente y en
lugar de que yo ponga los 10 millones de
dólares de mi bolsillo es que voy a
poner solamente un millón de dólares de
mi bolsillo un millón de dólares míos
y voy a ir a un banco y les voy a pedir
prestado nueve millones de dólares para
que me ayuden a comprar este negocio y
el banco a lo mejor me dice bueno no sé
es mucho dinero es mucho riesgo y yo les
diré bueno porque no me cobran un
interés decente quizás un 10% de interés
y además este es un negocio muy estable
por lo que está claro que voy a poder
pagar los intereses anuales de lo que me
genere este negocio y si por alguna
razón yo no puedo pagar a sus intereses
ustedes pueden quedarse con el negocio
así que básicamente les estoy dejando el
negocio como garantía y al banco acepta
prestarme los 9 millones de dólares
ellos me prestan 9 millones de dólares
con una tasa de interés anual del 10%
y así que ahora que tengo nueve millones
del banco y un millón míos los voy a
usar para comprar el negocio y darles a
ustedes los 10 millones completos y
ustedes pueden usarlos para sus planes
de retiro para comprar alguna casa para
r dárselo a sus hijos para donarlo a la
beneficiencia no sé para lo que ustedes
quieran pero ahora la estructura del
capital del negocio se ve así ahora yo
si tengo mucha deuda use un
apalancamiento para poder comprarlos así
que aquí tengo un millón de dólares como
patrimonio neto lo que yo puse y ahora
tengo 9 millones de dólares en deuda con
el banco 9 millones activos al menos lo
que yo pagué fueron 10 millones de
dólares los pasivos son 9 millones de
dólares y lo que queda es un millón y
pensemos cómo va esta inversión
asumiendo que el negocio sigue generando
el millón de dólares anual veamos cuáles
son los beneficios de mi inversión de un
millón de dólares antes de que yo
tuviera una entrada antes de impuestos
de 1.5 millones de dólares 1.5 millones
antes de impuestos
tengo que pagar un interés por lo que el
10% de 9.000.000 va a ser
novecientos mil dólares de interés anual
por lo que además voy a tener que pagar
900 mil dólares de intereses que lo
anoto aquí menos 900.000 significa que
tengo seiscientos mil dólares por año
antes de impuestos
antes de impuestos y ahora pagaré
impuestos solamente de esta cantidad que
me queda que son mis ingresos antes de
impuestos lo bueno del interés
corporativo es que es deducible de
impuestos así que restó mil novecientos
mil a el millón y medio me quedan 600
mil que es de lo que debo pagar
impuestos sigue siendo la misma tasa de
impuestos por lo que es aproximadamente
una tercera parte por lo que nos quedan
400 mil dólares como entrada neta y si
vemos las matemáticas pues es algo
bastante bueno para mí iba a ser para
ustedes pero no ustedes me vendieron el
negocio así que esto es beneficioso para
mí y me quedan un ingreso neto de 400
mil dólares por año ya que es bastante
bueno pues mi inversión fue de un millón
de dólares y aunque pareciera un negocio
que no era muy bueno y aunque tuve que
pedir un préstamo y pagar un 10% de
interés de ese préstamo realmente está
resultando que si es bastante atractivo
el negocio para mí esta palanca sirve
porque ahora estoy recibiendo el 40% de
la inversión cuatrocientos mil dólares
por un millón de inversión así que como
pueden ver resultó un muy buen ego